hello everybody and welcome to my guide
to flipping in free to-play RuneScape
now this is geared to old school
RuneScape but it's pretty much
applicable to both so in this guide
you'll be learning the basic concepts of
flipping uh but also the items that I
used I personally use to make millions
of GP in freet toplay and even if these
specific items don't work you should get
some ideas of your own okay so let's
just jump into it here so what is
flipping well flipping is buying
something for low and selling it for
high it's super easy but there are still
some basic concept that you should learn
to make yourself more successful so to
start off I usually kind of classify
there being two types of flips they're
the flaster flips which have really low
margins but they're quick and usually
buy a bunch of the same item and they're
the slower flips these are usually the
more Uncommon items that you buy you
might only buy 20 or 30 in a day uh they
usually have very high margins on them
but you may take a while to buy them
good example of a quick flip would be
chaos runes because everyone uses them
they're thousands traded every day good
example of a slow flip would be like a
bucket Helm or party hat or just some
random trimmed armor something like that
so the pros to flash flips are that
items are in demand you won't ever be
stuck with them for a long time and you
can get quite a large amount of profit
in a short amount of time so you don't
actually have to like leave your account
all day for anything to happen um the
cons are they can be very easy to lose
money and while it is easy to lose money
on all of the flips what I'm saying is
even if the price shifts a couple GP you
can lose thousands just because of how
many of the specific item that you've
bought and there's lots of competition
for the items because they're common and
heavily traded the benefits of slow
flips are that you can make a lot of
money off just one item um the reason
for this is because there's a lot less
competition on these items because
they're rare they're not trade as much
and another benefit which can also be a
negative is that they're easy to AFK so
it takes a long time but you can just
put an offer in and leave it for a
couple hours or the entire day and you
can come back and still have made a lot
of money uh the cons are that it's
possible to be stuck with items uh again
because they're uncommon and for a lot
of them you do require some starting
cash because some of the items are
hundreds of thousands some of are even
Millions okay so to start off here uh we
have to start start by doing is finding
the margin now the margin is just the
difference between what people are
buying it for and what people are
selling it for uh so to do that you can
kind of see on the screen here you just
have to instantly buy the item for so
you have to put in a price that's much
higher than you normally buy it for um
so see here I put in
25K um so I instantly buy it so I get
for
14,400 and now you just want to
instantly sell it so the difference
between these two prices will be your
margin uh so here you can see I have
about 6,000 GP margin that's pretty good
so I'm going to go ahead and buy this
item so what you're going to do is
you're going to buy however money you
want for approximately what you sold it
for so I sold it for around 8,800 and
I'm going to buy 20 of them and I'll be
right back okay so we're back and you
can see we've successfully bought and
sold all the items now we didn't make as
much as we orig intended but I think we
still made about 50 or
60k um so we will just check it here so
a good way to check how successful your
flips are are by going to the history
tab um so all you have to do is right
click on the gr exchange go to history
and you can see right there we um bought
them all for 176k and sold them for
230 um now there was one extra I bought
just to recheck the margin but still we
probably made 50k and yeah that was
pretty
easy okay so we're going to do another
quick one here we're going to try uh
pure Essence this time this is one I do
quite often uh pure Essence really easy
it's a cheap item so I just have to
crank it up a couple GP uh so we bought
it for 11 and we will sell it
for 10 so it's just a 1 GP margin but we
can buy a bunch of these so you can see
here I'm going to buy like a couple
hundred thousand I think 20K never mind
so we'll do 20,000 and check back when
these have sold Okay so we've sold all
the pure Essence I really didn't take
that long it's really easy doing pure
Essence and we made 20K so I would
recommend starting with 100K now it's
not required but it will be super slow
otherwise you better off just doing a
free-to-play money-making method as
crappy as they are um but yeah when you
get 100K I would start with these items
here arrows are good bones uh a really
good one is monkey bones that has a good
margin on it basic runes chaos runes all
the different types of logs you saw pure
Essence works pretty well uh Team capes
are really good they're the 50 kind of
PC CL cape that you can get uh they have
good margins on them and are pretty
cheap okay so once you've reached 500k
uh you could start trying to flip the
items you see here now I wouldn't stop
using the previous items because they'll
still be really good they'll be more
effective the more cash you have um but
if you want to try these uh 500k would
be a good place to start uh the trimmed
and gold uh mythal sets the adamant sets
the Rune set and the black set are all
within the price range and they all can
have really good margins in addition the
party hat set and the Halloween Mass set
are pretty quick moving and they can
sometimes have good margins on them as
well now once you get to the 2 mil Mark
uh there are a couple other pieces of
armor you could try uh the Gilded armor
was just recently made free to play uh
one of the most expensive armor sets I
think most of the pieces are 500
800k um as well as the iron armor gold
and trimmed is possible to do with this
amount of money uh kind of varies how
much money you can make on these you can
make anywhere between 10K to 200k can do
really well on these but they are a
little risky because they fluctuate a
lot in
price and if you do manage to get 15 mil
I believe to the best of my knowledge
this is the most expensive free-to-play
item you could try flipping the Gilded
Scimitar uh which I believe right now is
upwards of 17 mil uh so I mean this I'm
sure you can make a mill profit on this
if you're lucky but I mean I wouldn't I
wouldn't risk it all into one item but
still it's an option if you end up with
a lot of money and are somehow still
free to play and that's about it so that
is just a basic rundown of how to flip
and free to play as well as some of the
items that I use on a daily basis to
make the money I do now I didn't go over
everything I know I know some Advanced
Techniques for buying and selling I use
some external tools to figure out the
prices for items but I think I might
save that for another video cuz it might
get too long otherwise so if you're
interested in that uh I would appreciate
if you left the video like and uh
subscribe if you want to see more all
right I'll see you guys next time
[Music]